this lip therapy vaseline works
flawlessly for me if your lips look dry
more than likely your breath smell like
ash and feet
this is yours truly watch the rhymes and
these are my essentials
through my years of experience one of my
big pet peeves especially when i'm out
and about it in the club and everybody
got to get close to each other so that
you can hear each other talking because
the music's too loud
i can't take it when somebody talking
close to me and they grab someone like
ass and foot
so tic tacs is the first primary
essential
please everyone you need this to be your
essential tool my favorite
tic tac flavor is the white peppermint
flavor whenever i need these joints
i just tell my dudes to go in the store
for me and get me the white tic tacs
this is a very important essential not
just for me but should be for everybody
else too
let's move on to essential number two i
think a dry lip
is a direct implication and a direct
sign
that your breath might stand that work
direct in correlation with you needing
essential number one
so make sure you got the tic tac make
sure your lips is moist
so you got to have you a tube of lip
therapy vaseline i'm a big fan of this
because sometimes you might decide to
put a chapstick on your lip
and that's to dry your lip up too
vaseline just works flawless for
everybody
you've been getting vaseline put on them
since you was babies all right so we're
gonna stick with this essential right
here
lip therapy vaseline it's my favorite my
ancestry
historically has taught us he said we
need to look good feel good and be the
greatest
in every dynamic of our being i love
jewelry you know i was always totally
really get the emeralds and that's like
in the bottom of the cereal box
i always wanted to model my jewelry
after that and this rings it
particularly i got some
nice white bbs diamond stones i got some
red rubies in both of my pinky rings
nice little diamond gold bracelet and a
nice little dominant white gold
watch we all want to look good and um
i think i look really great in jewelry i
look even better without it because i'm
a handsome
but let's just know the jury just adds
the cascade dishwasher they can sparkle
another essential of mine
especially at this stage in my life i
really like to enjoy an incredible cigar
you know this this this brand of cigar
particularly is one of my favorite this
is a gurkha cigar you know this is like
when you really get to have your chill
out moments and you're celebrating the
moment you're just having a cool day
get you a nice little whiskey you might
get your little cup of zambukha
you know when you clip the cigar the
mouthpiece before you smoke
you just dip the mouthpiece in the
zambuka
smoke a cigar fly grown man though you
know what i mean we like to enjoy
cigars sometimes alone and you like to
enjoy
cigars especially when you are in the
company of incredible and great
cigar connoisseurs and people that
really appreciate
just the whole etiquette of the cigar
experience
this right here is a very important
essential as well
this is the torch the beautiful part
about this it works
hand in hand obviously with the cigar as
opposed to a regular lighter you know
when you get you a torch cigar lighter
it just helps the burn of the cigar when
you light your cigar
nothing like a good cigar that smokes
evenly from top to bottom
and you watch that ash grow longer and
longer and just sit
on the top of that cigar without falling
another very important essential i gotta
have a black washcloth i'm a hot blood
my kids are high blood my mother's in
high blood perspire a little bit
you know just over thinking you know i
definitely don't like looking
like i'm suffering from sahara desert
heat
so i make sure that i keep me a black
washcloth you wipe your perspiration
even catch a little itch or something
you gotta rub something on your face you
just the washcloth instead of your
fingers you know your hands you shake
hands you
touch all day you know it's just not the
most sanitary thing to do so
i keep my washcloth close by i ain't
gonna lie i have
a trillion black washcloths you know
what i'm saying another essential image
is the ipod
the reason why i like making sure i have
the ipod is because
i've had some horrible experiences i
don't really trust leaving too much
on the phone period this ipad i ain't
walking around with it every day
so all of my incredible music that i
stash on this is like almost another
backup hard drive just sitting somewhere
that i could get to and press
play quickly when i don't need to go to
the whole process of hooking up on a
hard drive to
play music and i also don't got to worry
about losing the music if i misplace my
phone because my phone is moving around
with me everywhere
and i love it sometimes you don't think
that ain't broke you know a lot of y'all
without pods no more but bus rhymes i
like to hold
on to the classic my next essential
obviously works hand in hand with the
ipod
it's the hard drive i at least walk
around with a hard drive whenever i know
i'm gonna be in a studio or i'm gonna be
around
other artists that i could possibly
record and collaborate you know
sometimes you go into different studios
or you in different cities and you got
to always be prepared
for the moment that presents itself
randomly to be able to capture a magical
moment
i like to record on my own hard drive so
when i'm recording
it goes straight to this hard drive and
when i leave that studio
it's only being saved to my own hard
drive
so i always have my in my possession
and we're not going to allow that to
exist on nobody else's hard drive
the next important essential for me just
because i like to travel around on a
day-to-day basis having certain things
that i'm gonna need to be able to have
within
arm's reach is my mcm bags
got a head of bags you know what i'm
saying now these are bags that i'm a fan
of and particularly
what i keep in these bags is none of
your damn business but they're
essentially that they're close by all
the time
last but not least gotta have a phone
every means of communicating
especially when it comes to handling
your business and being able to be
accessible when it comes to your loved
ones just gotta always have a line of
communication the only way
moves and shakes when you communicate
with people this is the iphone 11 and
particularly this song is starting to
make me a little uncomfortable
all these little damn crazy fingerprint
options and retina scan
options to turn you going on use none of
that i just stick with the little four
digit punch code and that's
it everybody in my household so probably
the coolest essentials
this is boston rhymes thank you all for
watching
have a blessed day